oh my first thought is is why there
needed to be two sausages this has to be
the only European version of an American
food that's larger this is good but the
order is wrong ready boom boom there you
go England come on
[Music]
pants look bright no idea what this is
though like this is not a sandwich and
this is not a burger I don't know if
I've ever had something with the mayo
and barbecue on at the same time that is
very well I would like a British thing
the mayonnaise and barbecue combo is so
strange
there's a few things going on and some
bacon more barbecue sauce it's really
good
it's a bunch of different flavors that
don't necessarily go together one thing
British people do better than Americans
always just fry them perfect it's like
oh yes the European McDonald's we can
have our little espresso yeah I guess
this is this is kind of cute it just
tastes like coffee it's just this is
just bacon is what I'm wondering like a
like a really weird barbecue sauce kind
of thing it's a lot it's like ham bacon
is like when we make tall Canadian bacon
maybe this is pretty good
okay so fries this is definitely a
smaller portion of fries they do taste
different and this is sad and sad for
everyone here it makes you suspect that
American fries have certain ingredients
that are illegal in the UK
[Music]